hey guys it's tuesday and i'm actually
traveling right now but i didn't want to
skip a tech tuesday because a really
cool app just came out and i'm really
excited to show it to you and i wanted
to make sure you guys saw it before all
of your friends saw it so that you'd be
cooler than them and you'd know about it
before your friends and stuff like that
[Music]
so this app is actually made from
instagram and it's called hyperlapse and
it's a really simple way to do
time-lapse videos what's cool about it
is a lot of time when you're doing
time-lapse videos it's hard to do them
like moving around you have to be really
still but i don't know what they do
they've got some sort of magic formula
that they make it actually look very
smooth let me just show it let me just
show you how it works oh look at that
it's my face
so you hit record oh great look it's
recording so i'm just going to keep
talking here just
just chatting away look at me just
sweetie swiggity swerving so if you see
i filmed about a minute of video i'm
still filming and that equals 10 seconds
so i stop it
and
there's your time lapse what's cool is
you can use this little thing right here
and slow it down
speed it up
click right here to click save look at
me saving away so you can choose to
share it to facebook share it to
instagram and if you want to make a new
hyperlapse well let me tell you what you
do you click make new when you click
save they'll save them to your camera
roll so you're able to go back and look
at them i filmed a 37 minute hyper lapse
of the sunset which ended up being
around three minutes
i will actually play the video for you
not on my phone so here here's a little
peek of it
[Music]
happy tech tuesday hope you guys enjoyed
this app i'm pretty excited about it
because i love new video apps i love
things that make things so simple to
make that anyone can really do it so let
me know what you guys think if you like
this video make sure you guys hit like
if you enjoy tech tuesday because i
really love doing these so hopefully you
guys enjoy them too i'm gonna actually
go to bed because i have to get up early
and get on a plane so i love you i'll
see you guys soon uh let me know if you
guys have any suggestions for next
week's tech tuesday i've got a couple of
ideas so
we'll see what you think
[Music]